well I don't know if you uh have heard
about this but something really is
really popular these days with the kids
are video games
let's play the video games and even more
than that they uh apparently kids will
also sit and watch other people play
video games
on the internet
I want to judge you for that if you if
you do that but then again I will sit
and watch a YouTube video of somebody
bass fishing for two and a half hours
look at Cody's fish show him the belly
on that thing yeah give him a dang
spanking too I've been a little naughty
today so I guess I can't really Judge
Too Much so today I'm going to play a
video game and I guess offer my review
of it or something last video game
system I owned was
and the last one I played was Super
Nintendo I was big Super Mario Brothers
fan Super Mario World rather we're gonna
give this a shot this is um
what is this that I'm playing this is
Call of Duty it's a Call of Duty Modern
Warfare
Call of Duty Modern Warfare is what this
is and we'll uh I've literally never
played a game like this in my entire
life but we will I don't even know how
to start it they gave me the quick
tutorial and I already forgot how to how
do I start it so you're gonna push the x
button to begin the game okay
X
all right we're in London
what's the mission can I skip past all
the I don't care about the story I just
want to get I want to get into shooting
people that's the main thing I'm into
here
it's only about a 20 second cut scene
and then you'll get to the action
like we're on our own Lads we'll handle
it
hey firm Sergeant yeah these Graphics
are pretty impressive I gotta say these
are pretty fancy graphics
that that is the level of a review
you're going to get from me these are
some fancy Graphics all right that's
so let's
first of all I'm not seeing any coins to
collect
are there any like mushrooms that will
make me grow tall or help me fly not in
war how do I shoot
you broke the rules of engagement don't
shoot first what what is the fun of a
video game where you can't shoot first
we're letting out our violent fantasy so
we so we because so we don't do it in
real life isn't that the whole point oh
God I just stabbed a parking attendant
where's the button to turn myself in
what's happening right now
oh
what can I jump on them and make them
disappear
how do I jump
X the x button
but if I jump that won't do anything
can I kick
no
no how do I duck
I don't know what's happening right
first of all this is can I just say
something before we continue the
graphics are impressive very fancy very
real looking
but isn't the whole you know for me
going back to my childhood
playing Super Mario World
you know you're you're in this cartoon
you're in you're in basically someone
else's LSD hallucination and I thought
that was sort of the point so what's
what's the if I want to be in reality
then
if I want to be in an environment that
looks like a a street I'll just go out
to the street
well this looks almost like the real
world well it's the real world's right
here you know what I could just look
away from the TV and look over here whoa
those are good graphics
so I know there's almost too much
realism for me it's not
you know it's clear that the left is
giving up their morals and any Common
Sense there's no better time than to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you're
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
Paulo is the number one Christian Prayer
app in the U.S it's helped me maintain a
daily prayer routine it can help you to
download the app for free at howlo.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
and track your progress along the way
not sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast available on the app for a brief
daily readings and Reflections or you
can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
as well with how low you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using
hello to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community as well ultimately
we'll learn how we can become better
individuals in spite of today's broken
World As We strive to become more like
Christ in our daily lives through prayer
fasting and giving download hello.com
Matt Walsh and get an exclusive three
months free that's three months
absolutely free at hello.com Matt Walsh
okay how do I switch my weapon to get
something a little bit more uh a gun on
the ground and push square a gun on the
ground okay where's the gun on the
ground walk the opposite direction it's
it's I'm turning around way too fast
oh right there
now I wanted like a bazooka or something
I'd have like a machine gun or let's get
let's get going here let's start
shooting some people
oh
God
so there's been a terrorist attack in
London and now
we're going out to kill the terrorists
my team has deserted me there
you're walking away from the action
wait how do I get back to it I didn't
I wanted to go around the corner and cut
them up cut off the bad guys on the
other side this big brain time all right
well maybe the civilians should get out
of the freaking way what are you doing
running through live fire you morons
[Music]
well get down get behind a car or
something get down go
I didn't even shoot that guy I didn't
shoot him
okay I did shoot that guy
you know what this is their fault I'm
I'm just
firing and
I got this guy
[Music]
that's your teammate oh well how do I
get back to that
[Music]
wait a second I'm shooting the sky
how am I doing so far pretty poorly
a good soldier if I've ever seen one
I I can tell you right now
um I'm not a video game fan
because you know somewhat infamously you
know there's kind of a story behind that
sort of a traumatic story but this is
actually my my maybe my super my super
villain origin story because I want it
in 1064 for Christmas in 64. rules and I
was told by my parents oh yeah we'll get
you Nintendo for Christmas and so I was
bragging about it I'm gonna get N64 for
Christmas and then Christmas comes and
all my friends get n64. and I got the
Super Nintendo and then I went to school
the next day and everyone was talking
about their n64s and I don't want to be
embarrassed so I lied and said that I
got N64 too and they were asking me what
kind of games did you play what kind of
games oh you know yeah that's the normal
ones and it was this whole Web of Lies
until finally it was exposed when some
friends came over and saw that I only
had a Super Nintendo anyway the point is
maybe that's the reason why I've always
hated video games and I don't play them
now or it's possible I don't play them
now because I'm uh what do you call it a
grown-up I'm a grown ass man and that's
really the main thing all right I'll try
one more time
what what's the objective I I kill the
terrorists and then just to stay alive
my objective now is just to survive for
more than 30 seconds all right I feel
pretty safe here apparently not
find this plant here oh
oh he's right there
I got him right in the crotch do I not I
don't get extra lives or do I get
there's not a video game thing I'm just
gonna keep going
I'm charging into a line of fire
taking fire but it's all right
this is courage right now on my part
courageous Soldier is a Dead Soldier as
they say and there I go
I think I did pretty well all things
considered
[Music]